là je pense que nous sommes au complet
je vous remercie d'être venu en nombre
pour participer à cette dernière table
ronde que nous avons que nous organisons
de la série d'auditions que nous avons
commencé en début d'après-midi avec une
table ronde sur l'isolation une autre
table ronde sur les matériaux biosourcés
et donc aujourd'hui pour terminer stable
ronde sur les énergies qui rassemble
bien sûr plusieurs acteurs du secteur de
l'énergie alors nous recevons ainsi des
représentants de cinq organismes
j'espère que je n'oublierai personne
Monsieur Bruno cap dordy vice-président
de vignès et Madame Anne-Sophie Périssa
Faber qui est délégué général constitué
de 38 entreprises alors je sais pas si
on dit l'inès nickness l'ignès
et l'alliance des industriels proposant
des solutions électriques et numériques
au service des bâtiments et de leurs
occupants madame Cindy de Michel
présidente et co-fondatrice de Celsius
énergie start-up de géo énergie
représente le collectif France géo
énergie au côté de Madame Armelle
Langlois directrice du pôle performance
durable de VINCI Construction ce jeune
collectif créé en novembre 2022 a pour
mission de rendre visible le potentiel
et la pertinence de la géothermie et
d'accompagner particulier et
professionnels dans le déploiement de
cette solution de chauffage et de
rafraîchissement
la Fédération des services énergies
environnement la feden est représentée
ici par Monsieur Pierre de Montlivault
son président la feden regroupe 7
syndicats et 500 entreprises engagées
pour l'efficacité énergétique le
développement d'énergie renouvelable et
la récupération thermique Madame
Christine Goubet Milot représente
l'union française de l'électricité en sa
qualité de présidente l'uefe regroupe
500 entreprises et représentent
l'ensemble des acteurs qui sont présents
sur la chaîne de valeur du secteur
électrique français enfin Monsieur
Thierry Chapuis président de France gaz
maritime et délégué général de France
Gall représente ce syndicat
professionnel de l'industrie gazière
française qui couvre le gaz naturel
renouvelable l'hydrogène et le GPL
mesdames et messieurs dans vos diverses
fonctions que je viens de rappeler vous
intervenez dans le domaine de l'énergie
dans différents secteurs
géothermie réseau de chaleur gaz énergie
renouvelable électricité pilotage des
consommations afin d'atteindre nos
objectifs de décarbonation à horizon
2050 le secteur du logement doit
drastiquement diminuer ses consommations
d'énergie et réduire ses émissions de
gaz à effet de serre l'optimisation
l'optimisation des consommations et le
recours à des modes de chauffage
décarbonés sont deux solutions
communément admises pour y parvenir
si l'électrification des modes de
chauffage contribuent à la décarbonation
du secteur le tout électrique n'est pas
une solution envisageable il s'agit
d'une impasse technique nos capacités de
production n'étant pas en mesure
d'alimenter un parc de logement
massivement chauffé et refroidie à
l'électricité
quelles opportunités peuvent donc offrir
les réseaux de chaleur et la géothermie
en termes de décarbonation et
d'efficacité énergétique
ces deux modes de chauffage et de
refroidissement semble insuffisamment
développé au regard de la qualité tel
que de faibles émissions de chaleur
issues de sources d'énergie renouvelable
en majorité de facilité de raccordement
ainsi que de confort d'été de même
quelles perspective le biogaz peut-il
offrir cette source d'énergie décarbonée
peut-elle participer à une
diversification du mix de chauffage et
d'eau chaude sanitaire du logement
s'agissant de la diminution de nos
consommations comment les solutions de
pilotage peuvent être peuvent-elles être
massifiées afin de garantir une
optimisation et donc une baisse des
consommations ainsi qu'une prise de
conscience collectif de nos usages
finalement pour assurer une réponse et
une adaptation du secteur quels sont les
besoins en termes de formation tant des
jeunes que des professionnels actifs
pour vos filières avant de vous laisser
la parole pour répondre à ses premières
questions pour donc il me revient de
vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct mais également en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat et
qu'un compte rendu sera publié
je dois également vous rappeler qu'un
faux témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de 3 ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende aussi je vous
invite à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité a levé la main
droite et à dire je le jure donc je vous
propose de commencer par vous Monsieur
Bruno capdordi et ensuite les uns à la
suite de vous demander de bien vouloir
vous prêter à se formalisme de prêter
serment
si vous êtes amené à prendre la parole
monsieur également
voilà on va le faire par mesure de
précaution voilà donc je vous laisse la
parole aux uns et aux autres et ensuite
notre rapporteur mais également les
membres de notre commission qui
assistent à l'audition pourront bien sûr
vous poser un certain nombre de
questions complémentaires par rapport à
ces questions un peu plus générale que
j'ai souhaité vous poser dans mon propos
introductif donc je ne sais pas si vous
voulez commencer par ordre on va
commencer par vous et puis après on
défilera si vous le voulez bien
vous mettez votre micro qui doit être
voilà c'est parfait parce que tout le
monde m'entend
donc Madame les présidents madame la
Présidente messieurs et mesdames les
rapporteurs merci de l'opportunité pour
le syndicat Inès de vous présenter
nos propos concernant les solutions de
pilotage dans le logement donc je
rappelle très brièvement qui est
Guinness ignès est un syndicat de
fabricants présidé par Benoît Coquard
qui est le directeur général du groupe
Legrand ce sont effectivement 40
entreprises françaises et européennes
qui sont basés principalement français
en Europe qui représente 300 000 emplois
en Europe et 100 000 emplois en France
ce sont des industriels qui travaillent
des PME des grands groupes et des et qui
travaillent sur les solutions
électriques et numériques du bâtiment
qu'est-ce qu'on entend par solution
électrique et numérique du bâtiment on
entend tout ce qui va être
l'infrastructure de distribution
électrique numérique et d'énergie dans
les logements ou dans les bâtiments et
on parle de logement ou de bâtiment qui
sont généralement inférieurs à 1000
mètres carrés
qu'est-ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui
dans ces bâtiments qui sont inférieurs à
1000 mètres carrés c'est qu'on a un
double effet faute d'équipement dans ses
logements et dans ces bâtiments on a
deux impacts c'est le premier
l'inconfort le deuxième une situation de
gaspillage là ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que l'inconfort aujourd'hui dans
les bâtiments dans les logements et
gérer ou être issu d'un manque de
pilotage des consommations énergétiques
dans les logements et dans les bâtiments
et principalement un manque de pilotage
de chauffage et quand on dit un manque
de pilotage de chauffage on prend au
pilotage pièce par pièce le deuxième
impact qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est
aujourd'hui c'est une grosse source de
gaspillage parce que vous avez dans les
logements et dans les bâtiments la
possibilité de gérer pièce par pièce ou
usage par usage et aujourd'hui le manque
de déploiement de ces solutions de
pilotage engendre des effets assez
facilement
compréhensible quand vous êtes
transparent d'une famille avec deux
enfants vous allez avoir jusqu'à 24
gestes d'économies à faire par jour si
vous voulez atteindre les objectifs de
baisse de consommation donc vous partez
le matin au travail vous allez devoir
faire le tour de tous les chauffages
pour éteindre tous les chauffages ou
baisser la température de ceci quand
vous revenez ou quand vos enfants
partent en décalé ils vont devoir le
faire le même geste donc aujourd'hui
c'est une situation d'inconfort ou de
non opérationnalisation des gestes
d'économies d'énergie de la pour les
familles qui sont dans cette situation
là
deuxième élément aujourd'hui on parle de
gaspillage parce que si vous oubliez en
partant de baisser la consommation
d'énergie ou alors si vous dites le soir
j'ai oublié avant d'aller me coucher de
baisser la température dans votre salon
votre salle d'eau ou la chambre ou le
bureau de personnes qui ne sont pas là
finalement c'est une consommation qui va
se dérouler toute la nuit donc là encore
une fois on pense que les situations où
les solutions de pilotage permettent de
résoudre justement c'est gaspillages et
donc ce gaspillage énergétique on peut
constater à la fois dans les petits
bâtiments ou dans les logements
dans le parc actuel on trouve des
solutions de pilotage on trouve des
thermostats mais on le voit les
technologies sont plutôt
usagées et donc on a des technologies
des années 70 dont l'interface
utilisateurs sont assez éloignés des
interfaces utilisateurs qu'on peut
connaître aujourd'hui et donc des
ménages où des utilisateurs de bâtiments
qui ne sont plus en situation de piloter
correctement ces bâtiments ces logements
on a besoin d'apporter de la finesse on
a besoin d'apporter de la réactivité et
on a besoin de s'adapter à la nécessité
du pilotage de la chaleur dans les
logements et c'est pour ça que on pense
que massifier ces solutions de pilotage
est un élément extrêmement important
aujourd'hui bien entendu vous avez votre
chaudière votre pompe à chaleur qui sont
équipés d'un thermostat programmable
néanmoins ce thermostat programmable il
est sur la chaudière vous avez peur de
le toucher ou la majorité des Français
ont peur de le toucher de peur de
dérégler le dispositif de chauffage de
plus ce dispositif de chauffage irrégule
une seule prise de température au lieu
de faire du pilotage pièce par pièce et
c'est la deuxième chose qui nous semble
extrêmement importante c'est piloter
pièce par pièce ou piloter à minima par
zone d'utilisation du logement et du
bâtiment c'est un grand facteur
d'économie d'énergie et ça permet de
s'adapter au cycle d'utilisation du
logement
aujourd'hui donc vous l'avez compris
nous notre objectif c'est de montrer en
tout cas de
d'exposer le fait que dans toutes les
expérimentations ou dans tous les
déploiements qu'on a pu faire le
pilotage des consommations via un
thermostat plus fin qui va agir pièce
par pièce usage par usage va permettre
de réaliser des économies substantielles
sans y penser donc en simplifiant le
geste d'économie d'énergie et on le voit
ça faisait partie de la notion
d'inconfort qui était évoquée et va
permettre de réduire la facture
d'énergie parce que justement le fait de
s'adapter au cycle d'utilisation des
différentes pièces du logement ça va
vous permettre de consommer quand vous
en avez besoin au moment où vous en avez
besoin avec l'intensité dont vous avez
besoin vraiment c'est trois paramètres
là qui sont extrêmement importants ce
sont des solutions qui sont en
auto-apprentissage donc elles apprennent
l'inertie du logement elles vont
s'adapter en fonction de la durée ou du
temps de chauffe du logement ils vont
pas chauffer pendant 30 minutes si seul
15 minutes sont nécessaires donc elles
vont compenser finalement la
méconnaissance de l'inertie thermique
des bâtiments et ce sont des solutions
qui vont être également automatisées
donc ça va permettre à un particulier de
pas regarder tous les jours comment moi
je dois adapter pièce par pièce ou
thermostat par thermostat ou radiateur
par radiateur ma consommation d'énergie
on a vu qu'il y avait un réellement un
réel gisement pardon d'économie
d'énergie sur ces solutions là donc
quand on parle de réel gisement
d'économie d'énergie ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'ADEME a publié une
étude sur les thermostats connectés qui
montrent que on est en capacité de faire
jusqu'à 15 % d'économie d'énergie nous
ce qu'on voit dans dans les études qu'on
a pu faire et les déploiements qu'on a
pu faire c'est que si vous
étendez ça au système de pilotage
connecté c'est à dire en pilotant
vraiment pièce par pièce on peut aller
jusqu'à 20% d'économie d'énergie voire
dépasser ses 20% d'économie d'énergie
donc on le voit les solutions de
pilotage de chauffage généralisé dans un
logement sont un apport pour les ménages
et elles ont finalement quatre effets
qui sont induits donc qui lorsque vous
développez ces solutions de pilotage
vont permettre d'avoir d'autres effets
le premier c'est limiter l'effet rebonds
quand vous allez isoler un logement
quand vous allez déployer une nouvelle
technologie de chauffage vous avez
généralement des ménages qui vont
commencer à chauffer un peu plus et donc
là avec la technologie de pilotage qui
est associée au déploiement de
l'isolation associée au déploiement
d'une ouverture de chauffage vous allez
abaisser cet effet rebond le deuxième
effet qui est extrêmement important
c'est l'adaptation du logement aux
personnes âgées ça va accompagner les
personnes âgées justement dans
l'utilisation de leur logement pourquoi
parce que vous allez avoir un système
qui est automatisé qui va se réguler
automatiquement et donc on va
accompagner les personnes âgées qui
souhaitent rester dans leur logement
troisième élément c'est le retour sur
investissement ce sont des solutions qui
sont peu onéreuses qui nécessite très
peu d'installation entre une et trois
heures d'installation donc ça veut dire
que vous allez à pouvoir déployer
massivement et rapidement cette
technologie là et donc on estime qu'on a
un retour sur investissement entre 3 et
5 ans enfin c'est des solutions qui vont
permettre également de répondre à des
besoins de flexibilité dans les
logements pourquoi parce que elles vont
permettre de réagir immédiatement à des
signaux qui sont renvoyés on l'a vu et
on l'a vécu cet hiver avec le signal
Ecowatt rouge qui était relayé sur les
différentes applications des différents
industriels qui ont déployé ce genre de
technologie en France
aujourd'hui ce qu'on observe c'est que
les politiques publiques qui sont
déployées autour de la rénovation du
logement sont des publics qui
fonctionnent finalement par technologie
et nous on pense que il faut raisonner
dans l'ensemble et finalement des
siloter les différents sujets entre
isolation chauffage pilotage et avoir
une vision d'ensemble du logement et il
faut également dessiloter cette notion
de confort et de gaspillage en hiver
tout comme de confort et de gaspillage
en été et donc la deuxième le deuxième
élément qu'on se propose finalement de
d'introduire c'est cette notion de
confort d'été ou de lutte contre le
gaspillage d'été parce que aujourd'hui
avec le réchauffement climatique qui ne
se profile pas mais qui est actuel on
voit finalement une accélération des
coûts de climatisation de ventilation ou
alors des logements qui ont été déployés
avec des technologies d'isolation et
donc des logements qui vont devoir
finalement se réguler ce climatiser
d'une manière pas forcément forcée au
travers de la climatisation donc c'est
pour ça que là encore une fois les
technologies de pilotage qu'on observe
aujourd'hui dans le logement donc ces
technologies de pilotage qui permettent
de réguler l'apport de calories l'hiver
avec un pilotage des volets roulants et
d'apport de calories l'été avec un
pilotage justement des occultants pour
éviter d'avoir la chaleur qui augmente
trop dans le logement combiné au fait
que la nuit que vous allez pouvoir
également piloter l'ouverture des volets
pour avoir un appel d'air frais avec des
systèmes de brassage dans le logement et
bien vous allez avoir justement une
régulation de la température qui va vous
permettre de mieux vivre dans votre
logement et de moins subir les effets du
réchauffement climatique c'est pas
suffisant en tout cas ça va permettre
dans beaucoup de cas d'avoir un meilleur
confort justement en été
aujourd'hui quand on regarde finalement
le pilotage dans le logement sur la
climatisation on a également des effets
de gaspillage puisque là encore une fois
si vous pilotez pas bien votre
climatisation dans les logements vous
allez gérer votre climatisation comme le
chauffage c'est-à-dire quand vous êtes
pas là ou alors quand vous êtes absent
quand vous partez en vacances on voit
des dispositifs qui continuent à
consommer de l'énergie là encore une
fois avoir un système de pilotage qui
permet de réguler et d'adapter à l'usage
du logement c'est aussi un facteur
d'amélioration de la performance
énergétique et de décarbonation de ceci
donc aujourd'hui cette notion de
sobriété ou de confort d'été divers elle
est inexistante dans les travaux et donc
on pense qu'il faut l'introduire pour
justement bien considérer ces deux
cycles d'utilisation du logement l'hiver
et l'été
je passe maintenant la parole à Madame
Anne-Sophie
justement sur les différents dispositifs
publics et comment effectivement les
solutions de pilotage sont ne sont pas
prises en compte dans ces dispositifs
donc clairement aujourd'hui dans la R20
donc dans la semaine 9 on va avoir une
prise en compte significative des enjeux
à la fois de sobriété d'été avec des
indicateurs dédiés que ce soit le degré
hors d'un confort ou le bio mais aussi
cette notion de pilotage du chauffage
par pièce pour autant on n'a pas encore
cette notion de pilotage connecté qui va
être intégré dans la réunion dans la
r2020 mais globalement on considère que
les signes en tout cas les technologies
qui sont adressées par ces enjeux sont
bien couverts au niveau du neuf par
contre il en est pas du tout de même
côté rénovation donc côté rénovation
dans ma prime rénov aujourd'hui c'est le
solution n'existe pas
on fait la proposition à côté de glace
depuis avec d'autres partenaires
d'ailleurs autour de la table depuis
longtemps pour qu'il y ait un bonus en
fait au moins sur les thermostats dans
les différents gestes de ma prime rénove
autrement dit quand je change ma
chaudière et ben je pourrai aussi avoir
un bonus pour installer à ce moment-là
des thermostats ou quand je fais une
rénovation globale je pourrais aussi
avoir ce bonus sur sur les thermostats
donc ma prime rénove aujourd'hui rien
côté C2E
donc on a des C2E sur les solutions de
thermostat malheureusement c'est des C2E
qui sont ce qu'on appelle à faible
montant ils vont vous rapporter entre 20
30 40 50 euros maximum ce qui fait que
ce sont des C2E qui sont pas du tout
utilisés puisque personne n'en veut
c'est trop lourd à porter pour le
professionnel c'est trop lourd à porter
en instruction aussi pour les
énergéticiens et donc on pas vraiment
cette problématique de distribution des
C2E pour les faibles montants donc il y
a un programme aujourd'hui qui s'appelle
Oscar dans le cadre des programmes C2E
dans lequel on essaie de mettre en place
une solution qui permettrait de mieux
les distribuer à travers les
distributeurs professionnels mais à
aujourd'hui c'est encore pas en place
l'autre élément sur les C2E qu'on
voulait porter à votre connaissance
c'est les enjeux des C2E sur les
solutions de sobriété d'été donc
clairement tout ce qui va être
protection mobile des volets des stores
et tout ce qui va être aussi
automatisation des ouvertures
donc là aujourd'hui notre principal
difficulté c'est que les règles en place
valent que la situation de référence
dans les C2E impliquent pour bénéficier
dans ces deux oeufs sur les solutions de
sobriété d'été que le bâtiment soit
climatisé
voilà donc ça c'est pour nous une réelle
ineptie réglementaire qu'on aimerait
voir bouger puisque en fait ça incite en
fait à l'incitation à ça incite à
d'abord mettre en place une
climatisation avant même de pouvoir
finalement installer des solutions de
sobriété en énergie qui vous aurait
peut-être permis de gagner quelques
années avant l'utilisation de la
climatisation et qui dans tous les cas
de toute façon vous empêcheront en fait
de limiteront concourront à limiter
l'utilisation de la climatisation donc
pour nous c'est une vraie ineptie
réglementaire et on aimerait bien que ce
point-là puisse bouger on comprend tout
à fait que dans d'autres sites constance
cette règle elle soit pertinente mais
dans le cas d'espèces elle ne l'est pas
et l'autre élément c'est que si on veut
vraiment intégrer en fait l'adaptation
des logements
au réchauffement climatique il faut
aussi s'interroger sur les scénarios
climatiques qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
notamment pour ces C2E et nous on
plaiderait pour que dans le cadre des
solutions sobriété d'été on puisse aussi
avoir un calcul de cumac qui soit basé
sur des scénarios prospectifs pour que
finalement la valeur qu'on apporte sur
ces solutions elle soit bien mieux
valorisées que ce qu'on pourrait faire
avec un calcul sur des scénarios passer
climatiques donc ça c'est au niveau des
C2E donc
au niveau du DPE donc on est aussi très
mal traité dans le DPE
alors il y a quelques éléments premières
informations qui existent tout de même
dans le DPE il y a aujourd'hui donc une
information sur le niveau de confort
d'été avec des petits smileys rouge
orange et vert mais qui sont finalement
basés que sur la présence ou non d'un
logement traversant de brasseurs d'air
ou de volets on a aucune information sur
ni la performance de ces solutions ni la
qualité de ces solutions donc c'est
aujourd'hui très insuffisant on a une
autre information éparse dans le DPE qui
concerne au niveau de la description des
équipements techniques où on va avoir
une case pilotage là aussi on va vous
répondre présence oui ou non de
solutions qui permettent une régulation
plus que basique du chauffage puisqu'on
est juste sur un mode l'existence d'un
bouton qui fait jour nuit en fait sur
votre radiateur
et donc ça c'est juste l'information et
au niveau de la valorisation bien sûr
dans la méthode de calcul qui donne les
tickets énergétique bien évidemment
ces solutions sont aussi très mal
valorisées
voire quasiment inexistante dans les
calculs donc c'est des points pour nous
important qu'on puisse faire bouger en
fait le DPE parce que ça reste et c'est
devenu un élément clé en fait de
discussion de de compréhension des
enjeux de proposition aussi pour les
professionnels et de dialogues et donc
il nous semble essentiel qu'on puisse
intégrer ces éléments de sobriété dans
le DPE à la fois de façon informatique
avec effectivement une description
claire des équipements présents dans
votre logement et puis bien sûr une
valorisation autant que possible dans la
méthode puisque sur l'étiquette il y a
des économies d'énergie réelle qui sont
à la clé et puis enfin dans les
recommandations aussi des
diagnostiqueurs qui peuvent être faites
sur ces sur ces solutions donc
aujourd'hui en résumé vous voyez qu'on
est très loin d'avoir intégré ces enjeux
à la fois de sobriété d'été pour
l'adaptation des logements ces enjeux de
pilotage dans dans les réglementations
concernant l'existant
très bien mesdames
bonjour Merci pour cette opportunité
donc donner à ce à ce nouveau collectif
France géo énergie qui est né donc en
novembre dernier suite à plusieurs
actions actions du
rapport de sorti par le Home commissaire
au Plan au Commissariat au Plan urgence
climatique la géothermie de surface donc
cette géo énergie une arme puissante
contre le réchauffement climatique et
pour et pour et pour la stratégie
énergétique française et le plan
national donc qui est sorti en février
par les ministères et notamment le
madame la ministre Agnès Penny rinaché
donc France géo NRJ on regroupe déjà une
quarantaine d'acteurs du monde du
bâtiment donc beaucoup d'usagers pas
seulement et des professionnels et des
usagers donc
usagers des énergéticiens des membres du
des entreprises de construction des des
professionnels du monde de l'immobilier
donc des fon faire des des promoteurs et
puis des professionnels de la géothermie
à l'origine de ce de ce collectif
l'univers l'université de la ville de
demain et de l'Institut Palladio portée
par l'Institut de la Fondation de France
et donc cette envie de systématiser le
recours à la géo énergie donc cette
géothermie de dite de surface et j'y
reviendrai
donc ça a été porté par différents
acteurs dont celle-ci s'énergit dont est
coince dont le BRGM est vite voilà
vite
rattraper par ma part tous ces acteurs
qui s'engagent aujourd'hui
peut-être je vais commencer par un c'est
la géothermie n'est pas n'est pas
nouvelle parce que la géothermie c'est
depuis des milliers d'années mais juste
une un tout petit une toute petite
réflexion sur ce qu'est la géo énergie
donc la géothermie de surface donc il y
a deux types de géothermie et je
laisserai
mes amis de la feden parler de celle qui
va sur réseau de chaleur pour une ville
donc je rêve ça il y a la géothermie
dite de surface ou énergie qui va
chercher sous le bâtiment dans les 200
premiers mètres sous le bâtiment une
batterie de calories et elle va les
prendre en hiver pour sauver le bâtiment
et les remettre en été pour climatiser
quand on chauffe et on refroidit grâce à
cette géothermie dite de surface donc
c'est à l'échelle d'une maison d'un
bâtiment d'un quartier et ensuite on a
la géothermie qui va aller beaucoup plus
profond on va aller là à plusieurs
centaines de mètres milliers de mètres
et on va aller chercher un aquifère à
1500 mètres par exemple sur Paris et
faire des réseaux de chaleur et là c'est
vraiment donc le domaine notamment de la
de la feden qui en parlera mieux que moi
et avec ces réseaux là on va aller
chercher donc très profond aller
chercher de la chaleur et faire des
réseaux de chaleur et ensuite on a une
autre partie qui est plus anecdotique en
France qui va aller chercher de
l'électricité donc là j'ai mis un petit
volcan pour pour c'est plutôt donc dans
les dans les outre-mer on va aller
chercher ça donc frangio énergie se
focalisent sur cette partie là donc on
est vraiment à l'échelle d'un bâtiment
et on va faire du show et du froid quel
meilleur exemple que d'être ici au Sénat
puisque le Sénat est chauffé et
refroidit par géothermie de surface donc
imaginons ce bâtiment là qui était
connecté au gaz auparavant certainement
et qui finalement est allé se connecter
à cette batterie de calories
et alors je vous propose une visite des
installations du Sénat après avec avec
grand plaisir on pourra s'organiser ça
si vous le souhaitez avec un très grand
plaisir c'est une installation de 2017
voilà une installation de 2017 et on
fera venir les professionnels qui ont
participé à ça avec grand plaisir donc
ce bâtiment chauffer au gaz quand il est
il s'agit de se de se connecter à la
terre finalement on a fait depuis et on
est allé chercher cette chaleur et donc
l'idée c'est vraiment de mettre une
prise à la terre et d'aller se connecter
à cette batterie d'aller chercher la
chaleur en hiver pour chauffer le
bâtiment à l'aide d'une pompe à chaleur
donc on est vraiment sur de la pompe à
chaleur géothermique et donc on prend la
chaleur en hiver pour chauffer le
bâtiment et en été on va prendre la
chaleur estivale du bâtiment et
recharger le sous-sol comment est-ce
qu'on climatise en général on en a parlé
tout à l'heure comment climatise c'est
qu'on prend la chaleur d'un bâtiment et
on la rejette dans la rue
c'est ça climatisé et donc on participe
aux îlots de chaleur urbain etc alors
que là avec la géothermie on prend cette
chaleur et on va la restocker dans le
sous-sol pour pouvoir la réutiliser
l'hiver prochain donc il y a rien de
plus de plus vertueux et quand on
remplace le gaz par la géothermie ici
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a
divisé par 4 la consommation d'énergie
de ce bâtiment
et par 10 les émissions carbone
donc c'est ça la géothermie c'est on
divise par 4 le divise par 4 l'énergie
est par 10 le carbone donc tout ça c'est
évidemment ça a été calculé par des
analyses de cycle de vie
global et évidemment ce qu'on dans les
politiques de rénovation en fait là où
s'inscrit cette géothermie c'est qu'on
est vraiment dans une démarche de
rénovation globale en prenant pourquoi
pas un étape numéro un la sortie du
fossile
sortie du fossile pour le neuf
évidemment et pour et pour la rénovation
l'idée c'est aussi de pouvoir s'appuyer
sur les sur le l'existant donc du gaz ou
du réseau ou d'autres choses et faire
des systèmes hybrides donc frangio
énergie en fait à vraiment vocation à
être un bras armé opérationnel donc on
est on est nous ne sommes pas des nous
ne sommes pas des professionnels de des
affaires publiques mais nous sommes
vraiment des entreprises engagées pour
opérationnellement systématiser ce
recours au niveau des aides et Armel on
parlera peut-être un petit peu plus tout
à l'heure le fond chaleur de l'ADEME
évidemment le gros le gros levier et il
y a pas je dirais dans le dans la
méritocratie du fond chaleur la
géothermie arrive au la géo énergie
arrive en deuxième position les réseaux
de chaleur sont là également et en
termes de subventions et d'argent
investie pour décarboner la géo énergie
géothermie de surface et quasiment
imbattable c'est pour en termes de 2
euros par tonnes de carbone évité
[Musique]
si je dézoom un petit peu que je regarde
nos amis nos amis européens et notamment
par exemple la Suisse la Suisse fort 8
fois plus s'installe 8 fois plus de
géothermie de surface de géo énergie que
la France pour un pays qui est huit fois
plus petit donc il y a énormément de
marge et quand je vais vous montrer ce
petit ce petit schéma ici en fait en
France il n'y a que 97% du territoire
qui éligible 97%
métropole de Chartres qui disait qu'il
avait divisé par 10 sa facture
énergétique en branchant sa mairie et on
peut imaginer donc un des acteurs qui
est intéressé également par ce sujet sa
direction immobilière de l'État 100000
mètres carrés de bâtiments si l'État a
été connecté à cette ressource
inépuisable on imaginerait le poids
qu'on enlèverait des ressources et de
des factures de l'État je parle même pas
de la souveraineté puisque c'est une
énergie évidemment évidemment locale je
suis géologue de formation et c'est pour
ça que je serais contente de vous en
dire un peu plus
sur sur
les enjeux on en parlait de passer
l'hiver comment on passe l'hiver
évidemment on se connectant à des
ressources locales quand on sur un
projet alors nous ça prend pas quelques
heures d'installation mais ça prend
quelques mois si on se décide
aujourd'hui pour passer un bâtiment en
rénovation à la géo énergie on va
prendre quelques mois on sera prêt pour
le prochain pour le prochain hiver
évidemment il y a les enjeux de passer
l'été on en a parlé comment on fait en
sorte pour que nos se multiplie pas les
solutions
inefficaces et et après avec des
nuisances sonores visuelles et des
contributions aux îlots de chaleur c'est
justement pareil en cherchant des
solutions de climatisation certes mais
aussi de rafraîchissement donc plutôt
presque passif de l'eau technologies on
appelle ça de la lothèque et cette
énergie s'y prête particulièrement
en termes de de formation il y a de
grands leviers en termes financiers une
solution de géo énergie on va avoir un
retour sur investissement de l'ordre de
5 à 15 ans en prenant en compte les les
aides notamment du fond chaleur on va
aborder plus tard des modèles aussi
financiers qui permettent de lisser
l'investissement de départ et qui va et
qui vont permettre et là on a une
structuration du marché qui s'opère avec
des grands acteurs pour pouvoir lisser
cet investissement sur le long terme et
avec des des entreprises qui vont
pouvoir avoir des capacités d'ensemble
liés et de faciliter tout ça on parle en
fait de la géothermie de la géo énergie
comme le sucre rapide de la
décarbonation c'est à dire c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui tout
de suite cette étape numéro une dont on
parle cette sortie du fossile et voilà
divisée par 4 l'énergie par 10 le
carbone et c'est une belle image qui
nous a été proposée par un Nexity et que
je reprends que je reprends fortement
alors
c'est tellement magique qu'on se demande
pourquoi on en a pas plus donc
aujourd'hui la géothermie c'est 1% de la
chaleur en France donc c'est peu et on
est évidemment à un tournant un tournant
énergétique évident sur laquelle je vais
pas revenir il y a un besoin très très
fort de formation de formation du public
de du grand public de formation
technique des des bureaux d'études des
services techniques des collectivités
etc des territoires aussi donc avec
France géo énergie on a 15 villes de
action cœur de ville qui se porte pilote
donc des villes comme 7 comme Draguignan
comme comme Niort comme Chartres comme
beaucoup d'autres que vous retrouverez
sur avec frangio énergie et qui veulent
déployer massivement viabiliser
finalement leur sol pour non seulement
pour réduire leur facture énergétique
mais aussi pour être plus attractif pour
pour les pour les différentes pour les
différents activités sur leur territoire
donc on va les accompagner sur ces
sujets là et puis de formation voilà de
de des acteurs des acteurs et des et des
Foreurs aussi puisque c'est une des
grandes mesures former 7000 fourreurs
pour pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
systématiser ses recours à ces énergies
là
peut-être je finis juste pour pour
montrer que
il y a une site il y a une il y a une
exposition
urgence climatique qui s'ouvre et qui a
été inaugurée hier par par
le ministre Béchu par jean-jouzel et
dans lequel la géomergie sera
représentée pour alors là on est plus
dans le grand public mais ça fait partie
des choses sur lesquelles évidemment il
faut jouer et je laisse la parole à
Armelle pour parler des aides en dehors
de de du fond chaleur de l'ADEME
merci beaucoup alors qui dit qui dit
j'ai NRJ dit en général et dans la tête
du grand public un très gros
investissement initial
c'est pas faux
c'est même très vrai sauf que comme
Cindy elle a bien expliqué on a des
retours sur investissement qui sont
rapides relativement rapide donc ça
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que si on fait un peu de financement
structuré dessus donc via des contrats
de performance énergétiques via
des opérateurs enseignés comme
comme le propose
le texte pardon France stratégie oui et
puis le texte du à 30 mars sur le tiers
financement
et bien il est tout à fait possible de
proposer des solutions sans mise
initiales donc que ce soit pour les
propriétaires et où l'opérateur est
rémunéré
les économies qui sont générés voilà
donc ça c'est des choses qui sont
amenées à se déployer et qui vont lever
le frein initial au déploiement de cette
géo énergie qui est le CAPEX
ensuite il y a des sujets de temps
les certificats d'économie d'énergie
sont des outils qui sont formidables
sur des gestes qui sont rapides voilà
quand on lance une rénovation une
rénovation globale à partir du moment où
en engage enfin jusqu'à la réception il
peut se passer deux ans trois ans sans
aucun problème et là le sujet c'est que
les certificats qui étaient initialement
engagés ne sont plus valorisés de la
même manière donc finalement on se
retrouve avec un des C2E sur lesquels on
ne compte pas dans leur globalité
et ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
quand on change de période de C2 etc
finalement c'est un effet rétroactif sur
les engagements que les soit les
constructeurs soient les mettre
d'ouvrage ont pris par rapport à ces
certificats d'économie d'énergie
ensuite
concernant
concernant ma prime ma prime rénova
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut comprendre alors je vais
parler je vais donner l'exemple d'une
copropriété ainsi une copropriété qui
veut être vertueuse et qui décide de
sortir du fossile elle va engager
à des primes rénoves et effectivement
elle va en sortir puis elle se dit
quelques années après je veux aussi
faire mon enveloppe et là elle est plus
éligible
parce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que un
enfin ce qui serait intéressant ce
serait d'avoir un parcours coordonné
dans le temps qui permettent en fait
d'avoir accès à ces aides
alors je sais pas si ça peut être via
vient un contrat signé initialement ou
etc et qui permettent en fait d'avoir
techniquement des travaux qui soient
incompatibles dans le temps et de
soutenable financièrement
je vais laisser la place à la parole à
Pierre
à tous et merci de nous avoir invité
parce que dans cette brochette je crois
qu'on partage tous des adhérents sauf
peut-être Ignace mais elle a fait d'elle
on est des gros consommateurs des
techniques et des solutions des
solutions de des entreprises d'Inès
puisque la feden vous l'avez dit c'est
500 entreprises dont les deux grands
métiers c'est les économies d'énergie et
puis la chaleur renouvelable et de
récupération et ce qui nous caractérise
c'est d'être des exploitants c'est à
dire d'être tous les jours dans les
bâtiments donc de devoir concevoir
construire ensuite exploiter des
solutions globales ou on va utiliser
toutes les différentes solutions toute
la palette de solutions tant d'économie
d'énergie que de changement de
combustible changement de source pour se
débarrasser des énergies fossiles et
aller vers vers le décarboné donc ça
nous donne ce point de vue particulier
de
de regarder ce qui se passe après les
travaux
ce qui est toujours un petit peu
difficile parce que on a souvent des des
promesses d'économie d'énergie et on est
parfois déçu les études les études de
l'ADEME le montrent par la réalité des
économies d'énergie
après après c'est ces travaux alors
notre domaine d'intervention c'est avant
tout la chaleur et je voudrais juste
vous donner deux chiffres pour rappeler
deux chiffres parce que je pense qu'au
Sénat on connaissait pas par cœur mais
là la chaleur c'est 43% des
consommations d'énergie du pays je crois
pas qu'on en parle 43% du temps lors de
nos grands débats sur la sur la
politique énergétique alors que cette
chaleur elle est carbonée à 65%. encore
aujourd'hui et ça ça a été dramatique et
ça a été regrettable depuis le début de
la guerre en Ukraine quand on voit les
impacts majeurs sur le pouvoir d'achat
de l'ensemble de nos concitoyens la mise
en danger de l'équilibre économique d'un
certain nombre d'acteur parce que les
prix du gaz se sont envolés et ont eu
des répercussions aussi sur les prix de
l'électricité donc ça a été dramatique
il a fallu en plus ça je trouve ça
absolument désolant dépensé pas loin de
100 milliards d'euros dans des boucliers
tarifaires qu'on aurait pu éviter de
payer si on avait été dans la prévention
et dans la limitation de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles depuis
bien plus longtemps d'autant plus que
les solutions techniques la géothermie
met plein d'autres elles sont mûres on a
toute une palette de solutions tant pour
faire ces économies d'énergie que que
pour changer de fioul alors sur les
économies d'énergie vous avez posé des
questions vous avez effectivement
gratter là où ça fait mal c'est comment
réussir à passer de ces monogestes à une
approche globale l'approche globale elle
est indispensable si on veut être aux
objectifs non pas 10% n'ont pas 20% mais
40% d'économie d'énergie dans les
bâtiments
et pour autant c'est pas simple donc
notre point de vue c'est qu'il faut
vraiment rentrer dans le détail le
diable se cache souvent dans le détail
et on peut pas traiter de la même
manière la maison individuelle
l'appartement avec sa chaudière gaz et
puis des logements avec du chauffage
collectif que ce soit les bailleurs les
bailleurs sociaux ou les copropriétés ou
que ce soit le tertiaire
donc pour nous l'approche globale qui
nécessite un vrai travail d'analyse de
bureau d'études pour identifier le
cocktail de de solutions les plus les
plus appropriées il est possible à
partir du moment où on a une certaine
taille de bâtiments et on a une maîtrise
d'ouvrage qui est professionnelle qui
peut rentrer avec l'entreprise dans
cette dans cette complexité donc là
clairement pour nous la solution c'est
le contrat de performance énergétique
parce que il y a une garantie des
résultats d’économie d'énergie on n'est
pas que dans la théorie en pratique on
doit atteindre la cible sinon ce sont
les entreprises de la de la feden ou
d'autres secteurs d'activité qui
interviennent sur ce sur ce marché là
qui paye la facture c'est comme ça que
ça marche vous consommiez 100 on fait un
diagnostic on propose un cocktail
d'action pour descendre à 70 ou à 60 en
consommation d'énergie donc on s'engage
là dessus si on fait pas bien notre job
et que vous consommez 80 c'est à nous de
payer la facture donc c'est voilà c'est
quand même c'est quand même très
engageant mais si on fait ça bah voilà
il y a un vrai retour sur investissement
pour le mettre d'ouvrage et puisque tout
ça est soutenu et c'est tant mieux par
par les dispositifs d'État il y a aussi
un retour sur investissement garanti
pour les euros public voilà on est sûr
de pas déverser de l'argent sans
retrouver les économies d'énergie qu'on
souhaitait voilà donc un outil majeur
contrat de performance énergétique je
remercie cette assemblée d'avoir voté à
l'unanimité ça va être d'excellent texte
cet excellente proposition de loi sur le
financement différé dans les CPE que tu
as que tu as que tu as mentionné voilà
ça c'est un outil simple il faut juste
que le décret sorte très vite que Bercy
coupe pas les cheveux en quatre et nous
ne demande pas des études préalables de
type partenariat public privé parce
qu'on sait que ça ça marche pas ça fait
peur aux collectivités c'est trop lourd
donc si on a un dispositif
d'applications simples moi je peux vous
garantir que on va pouvoir massifié
voilà
pour donc les bâtiments d'une certaine
taille pour la maison individuelle donc
c'est vraiment beaucoup plus compliqué
on n'a pas mettre d'ouvrage
professionnel il faut donc le monogeste
ça avait le grand avantage de la
simplicité donc c'est pour ça que ça
fonctionne comme ça pour le plus anciens
avec le crédit d'impôt développement
durable
voilà
il faut aller vers un parcours vous
mentionnez le parcours dans vos dans vos
questions ça nous paraît effectivement
le bon le bon compromis pour ne pas je
dirais faire que ce soit entre
guillemets une usine à gaz pour le
propriétaire du du bâtiment mais qui est
quand même une exigence de faire un
cocktail d'action et puis de le faire de
manière on va dire fragmentée mais quand
même relativement relativement rapide et
c'est pas mal de fonctionner comme ça
parce que il y a forcément un problème
de reste à charge quel que soit le
maître d'ouvrage et le fait de commencer
par des opérations à temps de retour
relativement rapide c'est aussi le moyen
de dégager une capacité d'investissement
supplémentaire on arrête de payer des
des grosses factures on fait des
économies qu'on peut réinvestir
successivement dans les différentes
étapes de du parcours de du parcours de
rénovation
voilà pour les économies d'énergie alors
un mot de chaleur quand même
la chaleur c'est formidable comme je
vous l'ai dit on a plein de solutions de
décarbonation et on sent depuis l'année
dernière si je dirais c'est le revers
positif de de la médaille de cette
triste guerre mais un bouillonnement
d'envie d'initiative je pense que tout
simplement un maire qui avait une
piscine chauffée au gaz et qui a vu son
collègue qui lui avait installé un
réseau de chaleur aux énergies
renouvelables et donc qui était pas
impactés ou peu impacté sur sa facture
c'est dit bah tiens ça vaut peut-être le
coup que je regarde si je si je peux le
faire les réseaux de chaleur qui
existent déjà dans 900 villes en France
vous savez que voilà il y a pas
d'obligation de raccordement les
demandes de copropriété de bâtiments
tertiaires qui étaient encore au gaz ou
au fioul de ce raccorder au tuyau qui
passe dans la rue ont été multiplier
l'année dernière entre 3 et 5 par
rapport aux années précédentes donc
c'est majeur c'est absolument c'est
absolument majeur et ça ça nous permet
je voudrais aussi parler de l'industrie
même si c'est pas le sujet de votre
mission mais c'est d'avoir une ambition
bien plus forte que celle qu'on
discutait lors des ateliers de la PPE
avant la guerre en Ukraine on imaginait
dans nos rêves les plus fous d'aller
obtenir 40% de chaleur renouvelable et
de récupération à horizon 2030 on a
refait l'exercice avec ce qu'on appelle
le club de la chaleur renouvelable
notamment le Syndicat des énergies
renouvelables amorce que vous connaissez
bien mais également les associations
spécialisées la FPG vous connaissez bien
le comité interprofessionnel bois
énergie enfin je vous le donnerai parce
qu'il y en a 8 je vais éviter de faire
toute la liste mais voilà on travaillant
sur ce nouveau monde depuis le
déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine on
on arrive à une conviction forte qui est
que d'ici 2030 on peut atteindre 54% de
chaleur renouvelable et de récupération
et ça dans tous les dans tous les
segments
à nouveau que ce soit donc l'industrie
que ce soit les réseaux de chaleur ou
que ce soit le bâtiment il faut vraiment
faire feu de feu de tout bois
effectivement la géothermie a une grosse
place si je devais quand même faire un
mériteur il y a une énergie que je me
permettrais de mettre avant c'est
l'énergie de récupération parce que
quand on a une énergie qui est produite
par un process industriel par la
combustion de déchets bon ça chauffe les
petits oiseaux comme on dit dans notre
dans notre jargon bon bah cette chaleur
il faut la récupérer elle est de toute
façon produite donc on peut faire des
choses merveilleuses maintenant on peut
alimenter les réseaux de chaleur à
partir de data center il y a des
chaufferies de combustibles solides de
récupération qui sont maintenant
possibles qui récupèrent tout le non
recyclable qui sort d'un l'ensemble de
tri de de collecte sélectives donc voilà
ces solutions nous paraissent nous
paraissent vraiment importantes et elles
sont insuffisamment développées dans
notre dans notre pays et puis ensuite on
a la géothermie on a le soleil on a le
soleil thermique dont la géothermie il y
a la profonde et la superficielle et la
superficielle on peut aussi en faire en
réseau de chaleur avec des réseaux de
chaleur qu'on appelle avec des boucles
d'eau tempérées si on a une nappe pas
très profondes où il y a pas forcément
suffisamment de degré pour chauffer
directement les bâtiments va relever
avec une pompe à chaleur et ainsi faire
fonctionner notre notre réseau et puis
il y a bien évidemment la biomasse alors
nous on est confiant sur la biomasse
c'est vous entendrez beaucoup madame
panierre une achète il y a oulala va pas
y avoir de la biomasse pour tout le
monde alors elle a parfaitement raison à
2050 si on cumule toutes les feuilles de
route de décarbonation des uns et des
autres ça ça boucle pas mais à 2030 avec
toutes les études que nous avons menées
donc avec le comité interprofessionnel
bois énergie
il y a moyen de faire en baissant la
consommation dans le domestique pour ça
il faut pas chauffer moins de logements
au bois mais il faut remplacer je
caricatures un peu mais le foyer le
foyer ouvert par des poils des poils
efficaces donc là vous allez avoir
beaucoup moins de consommation de bois
et ça ça libère des volumes pour aller
chauffer des industriels et puis de et
puis des réseaux de chaleur
bien évidemment le biométhane ça c'est
très important pour pour les réseaux de
chaleur parce que on est un peu comme le
système électrique on a des besoins de
chauffage c'est bête mais ça varie en
fonction de la température donc une
chaudière bois ou de la géothermie ça va
être très bien pour faire la base il
faut qu'on le dimensionne pour voilà
pour que ça marche tout le temps donc
résultat on va pas le dimensionner pour
faire 100% de la demande en cas d'hiver
très froid or on a donc des pointes de
demande et pour couvrir ces pointes il
faut qu'on ait un moyen qu'on déclenche
extrêmement rapidement et ça c'est une
chaudière gaz donc aujourd'hui les
réseaux de chaleur nouveau qui sortent
ils sont généralement à 80% de chaleur
renouvelables et de récupération et 20%
de gaz et donc pour les décarbonés à
100% on a besoin du biométhane de de mon
de mon camarade
voilà donc de très belles perspectives
encore une fois des technologies qui
sont matures j'insiste là dessus oui un
tout petit détail tout petit détail ça
s'appelle le fond chaleur de l'ADEME ça
a été bien mentionné ça coûte 34 euros
la tonne de CO2 économisée c'est
imbattable c'est la direction générale
du Trésor qu'il dit c'est pas moi
pour autant ça stagne un niveau qui est
totalement insuffisant donc pour vous
illustrer
c'est un demi milliard aujourd'hui
ça va être en 2023 entièrement engagé au
mois de juin l'ADEME
tous les projets pour consommer d'ici le
mois de juin l'enveloppe en fait elle en
a déjà dans son viseur pour consommer
750 millions d'euros de fonds chaleur
donc il faut il faut un PFR des
affectations de crédit sinon c'est tout
un ensemble de projets qui vont être
reportés qui dit reporter ça peut dire
que ça se fait pas au final parce que
les gens sont pressés où ils ont changé
de priorité ou on a des équipes
municipales qui évoluent donc il est
fondamental que ces projets se fassent
et quand on trace la trajectoire que je
vous ai mentionné pour atteindre 54%, il
faut être à 1 milliard d'euros en
moyenne déjà sur ce sur ce quinquennat
voilà donc d'ailleurs je crois que
certaines personnes s'étaient engagées à
monter son chaleur un milliard
faudrait honorer cette promesse bon ça
c'est le Sénat qui peut je crois faire
bouger les faire bouger les lignes parce
que quand je discute avec le ministère
de de l'énergie ils sont catastrophes la
direction du budget et voilà est-ce
qu'elle est donc
7 enfin on parle de chiffres qui sont
absolument ridicules au regard des 100
milliards d'euros de boucliers
tarifaires voilà donc entre le
conjoncturel et le structurel
je pense qu'il faut essayer quand même
de faire de faire du structurel
voilà j'ai fini merci Madame
tout d'abord bonjour à tous et toutes et
je voudrais saluer l'initiative du Sénat
d'évaluation des politiques publiques en
termes d'efficacité énergétique je crois
que la question de l'évaluation au cœur
de nos politiques publiques elle est clé
et donc voilà je suis l'intérêt de cette
commission d'enquête sur ce sujet
l'Union française électricité nous
agissons au niveau national mais nous
agissons aussi au niveau européen et je
voudrais signaler que de grands textes
dans le cas du fit for fifty-five sont
en discussion actuellement qui seront
très structurant pour le bâtiment bien
sûr un texte sur l'efficacité
énergétique mais aussi un texte sur
l'efficacité
epbd du performance du bâtiment voilà
donc là il va y avoir aussi des éléments
très structurants pour
pour les travaux de rénovation
énergétique dans le futur alors ça a été
dit par vous même effectivement le sujet
du bâtiment qui est aujourd'hui un des
secteurs les plus émetteurs d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre c'est à la fois
un sujet climatique mais c'est aussi un
sujet social en termes de facture
d'énergie dans la mesure où l'énergie
effectivement
et le choc de choc de la guerre nous
montre qu'un effet on doit et du
renouvellement de nos mix énergétique et
de l'indépendance énergétique associée à
cet enjeu-là on peut avoir un impact sur
les factures tout à fait direct d'où
l'importance à la fois d'engager
la rénovation et en même temps la
réduction des factures pour les ménages
et pour les entreprises et pour les
collectivités
alors au niveau des des solutions
bon je dirais que globalement on est à
peu près tous d'accord il y aura pas une
solution unique il y aura un nécessité
d'une stratégie du bâtiment segmenté par
type de bâti que ce soit leur
résidentiel le tertiaire l'industriel et
dans ces solutions on aura
probablement de l'électricité
qui aujourd'hui n'est pas majoritaire
loin de Vincent faux dans le bâtiment
des pompes à chaleur non avec les
solutions les plus performantes donc
avec des coefficients thermiques peu de
consommation beaucoup de chaleur
restituées rapport de 1 à 4 pour la
pompe à chaleur
de l'autoconsommation des réseaux de
chaleur et de froid vertueux c'est à
dire à partir de sources qui se
décarbonaient de la biomasse du solaire
thermique le tout combiné avait
l'accroissement du pilotage des
consommations quand évoqué nos collègues
de fitness avec qui évidemment on est
tout à fait en phase sur la nécessité de
mieux donner de donner aux
usagers en fait la capacité d'agir sur
leur propre consommation alors pour tous
ces différentes solutions
faut considérer que c'est le sujet du
bâtiment est assez vaste et que bien
entendu on parle d'investissement en
fait d'investissement des ménages
d'investissement des industriels et donc
c'est de l'argent c'est beaucoup
d'investissement
pour investir il faut avoir confiance
dans les dispositifs d'aide donc il faut
une vision nous dirions plus rien
annuelle des dispositifs d'aide c'est
d'ailleurs un minimum de stabilité quand
on s'engage dans un projet savoir que
ces aides y compris ma prime rénove par
exemple en loi de finances qui est
annuel et bien c'est un problème il
faudrait qu'on puisse profiter de la PPE
et de la SNBC qui vient pour donner un
cadre pluriannuel à ces dispositifs
c'est de l'argent c'est de l'argent
public alors il y en a quand même
beaucoup donc ma prime rénove de
milliard 4 les C2E pour citer les plus
emblématiques de l'ordre de 4 à 5
milliards donc c'est beaucoup d'argent
encore faut-il que cet argent soit
optimisé en termes d'efficacité
énergétique mais aussi en termes
d'émissions de CO2 donc de coûts de
d'émission éviter pour rentabiliser ces
aides et donc nous souhaiterions en
effet faire bien du premier coup et
aligner tous les dispositifs d'aide sur
le code de l'énergie l'Article 104 du
Code l'énergie pour que on prenne en
compte à la fois dans ces dispositifs
d'aide la réduction d'émissions mais
aussi une évaluation sur l'efficacité en
termes de baisse des émissions carbonées
dans ce cadre là
on peut aussi alors bon sur les contrats
de performance énergétiques j'y
reviendrai mais on est tout à fait en
phase avec l'idée de massifier ces aides
alors c'est plutôt vrai pour le
tertiaire on va dire ou les bâtiments
publics où on peut donner une force de
levier à cette énorme chantier de de la
décarbonation du bâtiment donc les
contrats de performances énergétiques
sont un levier pour cela mais on peut
aussi avoir à développer j'y reviendrai
sur les compétences des rôles d'ensemble
liés qui sont tout à fait
souhaitables pour industrialiser à la
maille d'un quartier d'une commune avec
le croisement de données alors je
voudrais introduire ce donner des de
cette question des données alors on le
voit déjà un peu avec les systèmes de
pilotage mais ça peut aller beaucoup
plus
s'appelait beaucoup plus en termes de
fléchage des actions prioritaires de
rénovation en croisant
les données du bâtiment que les
collectivités locales peuvent détenir
avec des données type compteur Linky
données de consommation donc là c'est
tout un champ potentiel qui permettrait
d'aller chercher les gros gisements
potentiels de décarbonation dans le
bâtiment donc il y a manière il y a
matière à massifier
et je dirais que
alors sans rentrer dans le débat geste
isolé rénovation globale parce que je
crois qu'il faut pas opposer les choses
à l'uefe nous sommes favorables au
parcours de rénovation
c'est à dire
finalement en 18 mois 2 ans sur une
durée
quand même qui soit maîtrisée anticiper
une rénovation performante par étape
au niveau des dispositifs d'aide
parce que souvent c'est rénovations sont
complexes on peut pas forcément investir
pour faire la rénovation globale et en
même temps investir et dégager de
l'argent public sur des gestes simples
c'est pas forcément ensuite une garantie
de performance sur l'efficacité
énergétique et sur la baisse des
émissions de CO2 c'est pour ça que nous
pensons qu'il faudrait pouvoir faire une
bonification des aides de ma prime
rénove dès lors que les gestes sont
engagés dans une logique de parcours de
rénovation dans un temps limité alors ça
renverra évidemment à la question des
professionnels je vais y venir pour
accompagner ses parcours
performant mais effectivement nous
sommes favorables au principe d'une
rénovation par étape
ma prime rénove
si on veut être dans une logique
d'évaluation qui est celle que vous
suggérez probablement qu'il faudrait
en fait
encourager le changement d'étiquette si
on veut évaluer le résultat d'une aide
accordée
sur la base de l'efficacité énergétique
et de la baisse des émissions de CO2 en
une fois donc il intègre un critère
carbone le passage d'une catégorie de
DPE à une autre
peut-être un élément objectivant de de
performance de la rénovation faite le
DPE existe
et c'est un outil qu'il faudrait pouvoir
développer à cet égard
sur le dispositif des C2E alors le
dispositif est assez complexe en effet
la question qui est assez onéreuse
finalement donc la question qui vient et
la qualité des travaux réalisés alors je
sais que c'est une un sujet qui
préoccupe votre commission en effet il
peut y avoir des échos délinquants qui
se qui se
qui se qui cherchent les effets
d'aubaine de ces dispositifs d'aide donc
c'est vrai que c'est pour nous une
grosse préoccupation
parce que plus le dispositif est
complexe plus il y a des moyens de
d'interférer dans dans ce type d'aide et
finalement de
nuire à la confiance des ménages ou des
entreprises dans la capacité à être
accompagné alors l'accompagnement
évidemment c'est très important donc
alors France rénove donc il y a une
consultation en cours en 2023 pour
changer un peu de mode accompagnement
avec un accompagnement qui associe
l'anal et collectivités bon ça on va
voir ce que ça va donner c'est
aujourd'hui l'accompagnement est assez
complexe dans ce dans cette dans ces
aides est difficile à appréhender pour
les pour les ménages notamment donc on
va voir ce que ça va donner c'est
nécessaire mais sur la question des
contrôles là c'est un point que je
voudrais souligner
aujourd'hui les dernières évolutions
législatives réglementaires sur les C2E
sont plutôt attachés au contrôle sur les
demandeurs de ces deux e c'est-à-dire
les obliger or les demandeurs de ces
deux œufs ce sont les fournisseurs mais
qui n'ont pas les moyens en fait de
vérifier la qualité des travaux réalisés
et donc ça c'est une recommandation que
nous souhaitons faire c'est qu'en effet
le meilleur contrôle possible et celui
qui touche les premiers maillons de la
chaîne
de valeur c'est-à-dire les artisans
finalement qui font les travaux
alors c'est pas pour que les
fournisseurs se défaussent sur les
artisans mais en même temps nous sommes
pas des professionnels de des travaux et
c'est important que les travaux ne
soient pas des contre-références et
aussi
d'écarter les disons les les échos
délinquants donc comment faire sans se
défausser c'est effectivement par la
formation c'est peut-être aussi par le
renforcement du label RGE
par des politiques de contrôle avant
travaux après travaux donc c'est pour ça
que les rénovations de performantes par
étape c'est très intéressant
voilà donc label RGE peut être à partir
des retours d'expérience tant de ces
deux oeufs que des travaux et des
contrôles qui qui sont réalisés
être un moyen de renforcer les travaux
la qualité par les artisans eux-mêmes
alors sur la formation ça c'est un point
absolument clé
on risque d'avoir un goulet
d'étranglement alors nous avons fait
l'union française électricité un édec
non contrat emploi prospective
compétences de la production jusque à
l'aval de cette filière donc avec les
électriciens du bâtiment bon le bâtiment
ça compte presque pour un quart des
emplois de la filière électrique donc
sur 600 000 emplois aujourd'hui c'est
près de 220 000 emplois donc c'est dire
que c'est tout à fait conséquent et on a
projeté les lape actuelle donc il va
être révisé donc à la PPE actuelle à
l'horizon 2030 c'est plus de 80 000
emplois donc c'est un chiffre très
important 80 000 peut-être jusqu'à 100
000 emplois qui vont être créés d'ici
donc ces emplois il est important
que nous indiquerions dans la formation
de ces emplois pour lesquels nous savons
que il y a des
déficits sur le plan de la tractivité
donc nous avons besoin alors peut-être
de stage enfin tout ce qui va être fait
autour de l'enseignement professionnel
et très important mais surtout la
formation c'est pas que la formation ici
c'est aussi la formation continue c'est
former tous les chauffagistes fiolistes
ou gaz sur des nouveaux équipements donc
les nouveaux équipements par exemple
pompe à chaleur ou géothermie
c'est absolument clé conforme sur les
nouvelles technologies baccarbones pour
pas avoir une guerre de retard et
d'autre part il y aura une numérisation
grandissante avec la pilotabilité des
équipements nous en avons parlé donc ça
ça doit être aussi le digital intégré
des lamants dans les formations et aussi
on doit moderniser ces formations avec
une la question de la traçabilité des
opérations des travaux si on veut aller
vers des
opérations par étape performantes il
faut qu'il y ait une certaine forme de
traçabilité donc ça c'est aussi avec le
datage numérique les photos post travaux
les signatures électroniques on peut
avoir toutes sortes de dispositifs qu'il
faut intégrer dans les formations
donc sur les formations il y a un
programme ces deux œufs fait bat il y a
Cali pack il y a un certain nombre de
choses qui existent mais probablement
qu'il faudrait avoir une ambition plus
intégratrice de ces de ces formations et
les rendre plus visibles
alors il y a un dernier point que je
souhaite aborder c'est l'accompagnement
des ménages parce que la question à la
fin c'est aussi le reste à charge
donc sur les barèmes d'aide
bien sûr on peut s'attacher à voir un
reste à charge nulle pour les médailles
ménage modestes en combinant plusieurs
dispositifs ma prime rénove mais aussi
aide habiter mieux sérénité de Lana ou
laisser deux œufs précarité donc il y a
plusieurs types d'aides mais
effectivement d'où l'importance de bien
intégrer ces aides pour arriver à un
reste à charge nul pour les médailles
les plus modestes pour autant nous
pensons qu'il faudrait aussi
renforcer les barèmes d'aide alors
peut-être pas tout le monde mais au
moins à des ménages aux revenus
intermédiaires
alors je vais pas rentrer dans les défis
etc mais les classes moyennes certaines
peuvent avoir aussi besoin d'avoir un
accompagnement dans les dispositifs
notamment de ma prime rénove même si le
reste à charge n'est pas nul il faut
néanmoins ouvrir ses dispositifs et pas
les limiter que au ménage précaires
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui un petit
peu restrictivement si on veut vraiment
soutenir
cet effet de levier sur les ménages
je m'arrêterai là dans un premier temps
et je me tiens à votre disposition pour
approfondir tel ou tel point
peut-être quelques je vais commencer par
donc France Gall c'est le l'ensemble de
l'industrie gaziaire on s'inscrit nous
dans une dirige une double baisse et
puis une une forte hausse baisse des
consommations et puis baisse de
du gaz fossile et puis une forte hausse
qui est la hausse du gaz renouvelable le
biogaz on en a parlé mais demain aussi
tout Le tous les gaz issus des des
déchets sur lesquels on commence à
travailler et qui qui ont un bel avenir
voilà donc
j'y reviendrai dans mes propos je vais
parler de donc du chauffage avec un peu
la question à quoi pourrait ressembler
un parc je dirais performant
peut-être que quelques conditions qui
ont été certaines ont été évoquées par
mes voisins la première c'est de c'est
de résoudre tous les freins que
rencontre aux citoyens en particulier le
la question du reste à charge qui a un
vrai problème alors peut-être une incise
sur le fait que
le bouclier tarifaire gaz s'arrête ce
qui est une ce qui est une bonne chose
parce que il s'arrête parce que j'irai
les prix du gaz ont baissé et que voilà
ce qui montre que l'industrie quasi a su
aussi réagir à la crise de l'Ukraine et
que tout gérer toute la hausse des prix
n'est pas dû évidemment que au gaz même
si le gaz
a connu des hausses fortes
voilà donc ce bouclier tarifaire reste
enfin va être supprimé ce qui montre que
les prix du gaz sont redevenus des
niveaux qui sont je dirais plus
acceptable
ce qui n'était pas évidemment le l'année
dernière
peut-être l'autre chose c'est que comme
comme l'a dit Christine c'est il s'agit
aussi d'augmenter assez fortement le
nombre de rénovations globale qui est
une bonne chose même si on n'est pas du
tout opposé au rénovations je dirais par
geste mais c'est vrai que le nombre de
rénovations globale l'augmenter assez
fortement c'est une un point important
il faut aussi lever quelques freins
administratifs c'est dans le secteur du
bâtiment
donc j'en ai parlé trouver un système
qui permet que le reste à charge soit
couvert le plus possible peut-être
cibler les bâtiments les moins
performants les f et les FJ évidemment
il est passé en CD avant avant tout
concernant le DPE c'est c'est le
fiabiliser aussi les mesures de DPE sont
pas toujours fiables et donc ça donne
lieu à des disparités donc fiabiliser le
DPE et puis sur les C2E tu en as
beaucoup parlé Christine il s'agit aussi
de
peut-être sur le bâtiment proprement dit
une alerte je dirais le les recettes
faciles sont souvent impossibles vous
l'avez dit madame la Présidente tout
électrifiée n'est pas envisageable et on
ça conduit à une impasse technique on a
je dirais ces derniers temps eu des
rumeurs d'interdiction du gaz dans le
dans le bâtiment qui sont qui sont qui
ont plus ou moins disparu qui se sont
transformés en proposition de limiter
fortement le gaz dans le bâtiment je
pense qu'on peut encore évoluer un petit
peu parce que dans certains cas je
dirais
il y a des cas où les options manquent
pour remplacer le chauffage au gaz je
vais citer trois exemples mais c'est
trois exemples il pourrait rien avoir
d'autre dans les dans la dans les
immeubles collectifs le type
haussmannien avec toi de zinc alors je
le cite parce qu'on est à Paris mais il
vous pouvez on pourrait faire des
comparaisons dans d'autres dans d'autres
villes c'est pas très simple d'aller
mettre
j'irai autre chose que du gaz et
en milieu rural aussi quand le fuel est
interdit quand je dirais le réseau
électrique est pas toujours suffisamment
dimensionné n'oublions pas que 25000
communes aujourd'hui ne sont pas
raccordés au réseau de gaz et ont
pourtant du gaz dans ces milieux là je
dirais le des solutions trop rapides en
tout cas pèserait sur sur l'ensemble des
ménages
et puis dans l'ancien mal isolé c'est
pareil les solutions sont pas très
simples
il y a un enjeu aussi autour pour de
financement je l'ai dit et plus
généralement de l'entretien des systèmes
de chauffage
les systèmes de chauffage sont des
choses qui nécessitent de l'entretien ça
a été dit également il s'agit aussi de
tenir cet entretien dans la dans la
durée
voilà et donc certes certaines solutions
gaz en particulier les chaudières à très
haute performances énergétiques ont des
entretiens qui sont gérés relativement
simple et facile
peut-être noter que l'ensemble des aides
ne couvre généralement pas tous ces
mécanismes d'entretien
et donc c'est aussi important dans la
durée d'avoir ces ce point là
sachant que les systèmes de chauffage
sont des systèmes qui durent et par
exemple pour les locataires quand on
change quand un locataire arrive dans un
immeuble ou un appartement je dirais il
récupère le système de chauffage qui
existe y compris les séchage d'entretien
qui peuvent être qui peuvent être
importantes
un point sur le la sécurité
d'approvisionnement énergétique global
notre avis c'est que ce point-là
continuera à se poser jusqu'en 2035 au
moins et l'arrivée des nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires juste peut-être un
zoom sur le récent en rapport de la
creux qui a fait une hypothèse puisqu'on
est dans l'hypothèse imaginons qu'on
interdit complètement le chauffage au
gaz donc la creux a fait l'exercice
partiellement en se disant si j'interdis
complètement le chauffage au gaz quelle
est l'impact sur la pointe électrique le
rapport conclut que ça fait 35 gigawatts
supplémentaires en hiver sachant que le
rapport ne prend pas en compte le gaz
donc j'ai vu que j'ai mentionné tout à
l'heure qui n'est le gaz qui n'est pas
dans le réseau c'était la creux c'était
que le gaz en réseau et donc là à ça il
faut rajouter à peu près 8 gigawatts de
pour le virer les besoins hors réseau
donc ça fait un total de 43 43 GB
voilà l'équivalent de plusieurs
plusieurs réacteurs nucléaires
voilà donc on est convaincu que il faut
en partie électrique faut pas aller trop
vite il faut le faire au rythme je
dirais qui est permis je pense que
dans tout ce qu'on regarde il faut aussi
regarder l'effet climatique c'est
important mais il faut bien le regarder
en cycle de vie et pas juste
je dirais juste derrière le système de
chauffage donc ça c'est aussi important
pour l'ensemble des moyens
typiquement si on remplace un chauffage
gaz direct et je vais parler dans un
instant du du gaz renouvelable mais par
gérer l'équivalent électrique et si la
solution n'est pas performante
évidemment avec le rendement des des
centrales à gaz de
50%, on perd un rendement et c'est je
dirais il vaut mieux utiliser le gaz au
plus près de ses besoins quand on en a
besoin on peut le mettre aussi dans les
réseaux de chaleur on est d'accord
peut-être un point donc j'en arrive au
gaz renouvelable vous dire d'abord avant
les les volumes que la filière gaz
renouvelable donc se développe mais elle
répond aussi complètement à l'enjeu du
made in France c'est une filière qui est
très française aujourd'hui très agricole
avec des sociétés qui développent les
méthaniseurs qui au début ont
récupéré des technologies allemandes on
n'a pas utilisé le modèle allemand par
contre on a récupéré les technologies
allemandes aujourd'hui c'est même
société exportent parfois en Allemagne
en Italie aux États-Unis et donc j'irai
la technologie qu'on a développé avec
nos 500 méthaniseurs aujourd'hui le
gazon Louvain c'est 10hwatters 500
méthaniseurs et donc cette technologie
elle commence à s'exporter au point que
certains réfléchissent à faire que de
l'export parce que bon on a
l'improvisoirement un problème sur les
tarifs sur la méthanisation parce que le
les métaliseurs connu une forte hausse
liée
à la problématique sur les prix de
l'énergie l'année dernière voilà les
méthaniseurs ont des mélangeurs qui sont
alimentés à l'électricité nos tarifs
n'étaient ni indexés ni sur
l'électricité ni sur l'inflation et une
forte inflation et j'irai ils ont aussi
subi le la hausse des coûts de l'énergie
et donc on est en train de relancer mais
devant l'absence de de
hausse des tarifs qu'on sur lequel on
craignait il y a six mois voilà
certaines sociétés se sont tournées vers
l'export et réfléchissent à voilà si un
exemple prodeval il se trouve que les
ceux qui sont la tête sont
franco-italiens et donc ils
réfléchissent à installer leurs usines
en Italie ou en France donc c'est ça
c'est concrètement que se joue les
emplois et là et la filière
sur le gaz renouvelable j'en ai déjà un
peu parlé donc je vais aller vite je
vous ai dit dites arwater de capacité
aujourd'hui
installée c'est pas exactement la
capacité qui a été produite l'année
dernière un peu moins parce que les
méthaniseurs se mettent progressivement
en route mais sur une année pleine ça
ferait 10h la filière estime que 20% de
gaz renouvelables et tout à fait
atteignable à l'horizon 2030 ça ne se
fera pas que avec de la méthanisation
mais c'est à peu près une cinquantaine
de terre en méthanisation donc cinq fois
plus que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui le reste
une dizaine de terrawateurs pour être
fait à partir de nouvelles technologies
innovantes à partir de déchets soit de
déchets solides soit déchets liquides ou
bien de la méthanation donc on recombine
de l'hydrogène qu'on aura demain et du
CO2 pour en faire du méthane de synthèse
donc toutes ces solutions sont sont
apportées de main
peut-être après quelques quelques
propositions parce que j'ai dit qu'il y
avait des je dirais des choses qui
étaient impossibles donc en particulier
une interdiction trop forte
quelles solutions proposées en gros
quelques idées pour les maisons
individuelles
je pense qu'il serait intéressant que la
pompe à chaleur hybride devienne je
dirais l'appareil installé un peu par
défaut c'est un appareil qui peut être
je dirais on en a parlé ici au Sénat aux
États alimentés par une alors c'est la
géothermie la pompe à chaleur marche la
géothermie mais il y a un complément gaz
qui qui reste important et je dirais
cette cette dualité est importante donc
le fait que dans les plus petits
appartements c'est pas de la géothermie
c'est plutôt de la pompe à chaleur
électrique avec un complément gaz mais
j'irai le fait d'avoir ces pompes à
chaleur permet de résoudre le problème
de la pointe et puis le problème de
enfin le l'arrivée du gaz renouvelable
pour les immeubles
en l'absence de de solution alternatif
parce que comme j'ai dit de temps en
temps il y a pas de solution alternative
je pense que encourager le remplacement
des chaudières à très haute performance
énergétique
permettrait une réduction assez rapide
donc si vous passez d'une chaudière gaz
classique une chaudière gastrique
performance énergétique c'est à peu près
30% d'économie voilà sachant que pour
avoir les chiffres sur 11 millions de de
clients gaz 11 millions c'est c'est sur
30 millions à peu près de de logement
donc 36 % vous en avez alors que je vous
cite les chiffres exacts que j'ai
donc sur
10,7 10,8 millions vous en avez 3,3 qui
sont des immeubles collectifs chauffés
individus individuellement et puis 2,5
qui sont des logements collectifs avec
chauffage collectif donc vous voyez les
chiffres et ces chiffres là
j'irai privilégier les solutions à très
haute performance énergétique nous
semble aussi
intéressant et puis peut-être un dernier
point ne pas négliger les problèmes de
voisinage dans la rénovation énergétique
donc faire attention à ce que la facture
est énergétique soit soit jouable mais
aussi ne pas ne pas négliger les
problèmes de voisinage qui sont aussi
importants
et puis en conclusion
je dirais que nous sommes convaincus
France gaz que que avec malgré toutes
les contraintes qu'on peut qu'on peut
qu'on a identifié la transition
énergétique elle ne peut être que
progressive et puis accompagnée
il faut qu'elle soit socialement
acceptable je pense que les Français
sont prêts à faire beaucoup les tout le
l'enjeu autour de la sobriété la montrer
son frère beaucoup mais encore faut-il
qu'elle soit socialement acceptable que
ce soit acceptable partout j'ai parlé
des du milieu rural voilà il faut que ce
soit vraiment acceptable partout et un
peu à la question que je posais au début
là à quoi notre parc de chauffage
devrait-il ressembler c'est avec un mix
énergétique qui a intègre toutes les
solutions il y a eu beaucoup de
solutions proposées aujourd'hui je pense
qu'elles sont toutes
intelligentes voilà il s'agit d'en
exclure aucune et de je dirais de
permettre à nos concitoyens de se
chauffer le gérer quelque part le plus
efficacement possible tout en
s'inscrivant assez fortement dans la des
carbonation de notre énergie je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur c'est à vous
merci madame la Présidente vous avez
déjà merci pour vos différentes
interventions parce que c'était déjà
très très
précis
moi j'avais peut-être une petite
question sur la question du pilotage en
fait de ce que vous avez expliqué mais
je pourrais faire ça a été abordé par
Monsieur sur la question de la
maintenance en fait et c'est vrai que
cette partie là en tout cas me paraît à
chaque fois importante parce qu'à partir
du moment du pilotage c'est vrai que
tout se passe bien
sauf quand du coup on s'en occupe plus
ça se dérègle etc et que et que les
choses se ne fonctionnent plus donc le
fait d'avoir en tout cas d'associer en
tout cas la question de la maintenance
ça me paraît sympa quelque chose
d'important
sur la question de géo de géothermie
moi ma question était plus sur en fait
en gros comment évaluer tout ça c'est
des coûts qui sont quand même
relativement importants que sur
l'individuel ça reste quand même des des
couleurs vous l'avez bien expliqué que
qu'on avait un retour assez rapide mais
en à quel moment et est-ce que vous
faites à chaque fois des études sur
justement l'intérêt d'un collectif quoi
et à quel moment entre plusieurs
installations individuelles ou
l'opportunité en fait d'avoir un réseau
de chaleur dans un secteur
peut basculer parce que c'est vrai que
si on reprend le système d'aide qu'il
est fait pour les pompes à chaleur ou
pour autre ça favorise pas tellement ça
quoi on est plutôt sur de
l'individualisation et en fait de pas
aller forte forcément sur sur des
équipements qui seraient plus plus
collectifs donc savoir voilà si vous
aviez
réfléchi à ça
sur le réseau de chaleur aussi j'ai une
question sur les questions de de réseau
froid ce que vous en avez pas parlé
donc chez Canal très peu je crois enfin
en tout cas c'est pas encore totalement
développé mais savoir si pour vous c'est
quelque chose plutôt de pertinent à
développer on a parlé du confort
thermique d'été qui était une vraie
problématique et qui était mal intégrée
en tout cas actuellement
dans le DPE et dans et dans le la
réflexion globale sur la rénovation
thermique est-ce que du coup les réseaux
froids peuvent être aussi une
alternative dans certains
dans certains cas et quand c'est quand
c'est possible à condition qu'on
travaille aussi évidemment sur sur la
question de l'enveloppe mais c'est vrai
que c'était quelque chose qui
m'intéressait
[Musique]
il me semblait voilà et puis après sur
le sur la question plutôt gaz c'est vrai
que je partage assez c'est vrai qu'il y
a peut-être une dérive en tout cas une
alerte à avoir pour être allé visiter
quelques méthaniseurs c'est vrai quand
on a un réseau de gaz et que du coup tu
fonctionnes plus de chaudière gaz ce
secteur là c'est vrai que et que et que
on va plutôt favoriser de la pompe à
chaleur on peut se demander un petit peu
la pertinence en fait de des
orientations qui sont qui sont mis
surtout qu'en général quand il y a que
c'est un méthaniseur c'est plutôt
quelque chose qui a été travaillé à
l'échelle locale donc c'est vrai que
chaque fois se pose la question en fait
de se dire est-ce que on devrait pas
avoir des
des financements et des orientations
plutôt locales et en fonction justement
des ressources et en fonction de des de
l'existence en tout cas des moyens de
chauffage qu'on peut avoir localement
voilà
alors commence Inès
alors sur le sujet pilotage et
maintenant c'est en fait il y a dans le
cadre du Plan sobriété 1 en fait on
avait avec l'uefe pousser une mesure qui
était effectivement
d'intégrer en fait les solutions de
pilotage dans les
entretiens annuels en fait du chauffage
et de la climatisation donc c'est un
écrit qui est paru et qui est
aujourd'hui actif et donc aujourd'hui
dans le cadre des contrôles annuels en
fait la personne on a élargi en fait son
SCOP d'intervention et il viendra
vérifier en fait que vos systèmes de
pilotage sont aussi toujours en
fonctionnement toujours adaptés avec les
bonnes mises à jour logicielles etc donc
ce temps il a été créé aujourd'hui dans
le cadre des logements est-ce qu'une
bonne chose on rejoint aussi enfin la
performance ça c'est pas un hasard ça
demande aussi des du capital humain donc
nous on partage pleinement l'idée
c'était d'ailleurs une proposition aussi
de notre filière électrique
de de d'intégrer en fait dans les
dispositifs d'aide tout ce qui va
concerner le commissionnement les
énergies managers et tout ce qui va
concerner globalement la maintenance
parce que c'est un élément clé en fait
de
de qualité en fait de maintenir les
équipements plus plus longtemps en
termes de durée de vie ce qui est ce qui
est important en termes carbone aussi et
d'économie circulaire et puis de
s'assurer que ça fonctionne bien et que
les performances sont rendez vous donc
investir dans le capital humain et il
reconnaitre comme éligible aussi dans
les aides ça nous paraît un point
important
et pour compléter techniquement
aujourd'hui toutes les applications sont
connectées donc on a une mise à jour les
applications en temps réel et toutes les
interfaces qui ont été développées vise
à informer le consommateur il y a la
formule justement si on observe une
dérive quand à la programmation de
l'application ou si on observe une
dérive quant à la surconsommation d'un
usage donc le but c'est de renforcer les
interactions également avec les usagers
pour pas que ça soit une application
inerte mais qu'elle vive avec
l'évolution de l'usager dans son
logement
je vais prendre la question sur sur le
coup et le côté individuel versus
collectif de de la géothermie donc on
estime aujourd'hui qu'il y a environ 200
000 maisons logements individuel
connecté à peu près donc 195000 et de
plus en plus en fait ce qu'on voit c'est
des logements collectifs que soit pour
le bailleur ou de la copro en moindre
mesure donc entre 200 et 250 300 000
logements connectés à cette joie énergie
donc cette petite géothermie il y a eu
un une baisse drastique du nombre de
maisons connectés à partir de 2008 et
surtout parce que les aides aux
individuelles sont tombés donc on est
passé de 22000 installations par an à
3000 et on est à peu près là dessus
maintenant pour compenser un petit peu
ça et on passe sur de plus gros objets
donc aujourd'hui les projets de géo
énergie sont en train de la puissance
installée et beaucoup plus grande
qu'avant donc on passe sur des sur du
sur de GoPro sur du bailleur sur des
objets plus gros
et notamment sur de la boucle d'eau on
en a parlé donc là on est sur des petits
réseaux donc là ça se passe on a on a
plusieurs exemples de ce type on a sur
ici les Moulineaux sur Nanterre et un
sur lequel je voudrais revenir et ça va
rebondir sur le sur le froid aussi c'est
le rose le réseau euromède donc à
Marseille donc là on est sur de la
thalasso aussi donc c'est utilisé l'eau
de mer notamment donc pour faire du show
et du froid et la condition qui a été
mise c'était que ce confort climatique
d'été ne devait pas se faire au
détriment de l'espace public ne pas
privatiser le confort d'été et donc ne
pas contribuer aux
îlots de chaleur et en fait en mettant
cette petite phrase la collectivité
c'est
c'était forcément de la géothermie qui
allait qui elle est qui allait qui
allait être mise donc c'est vraiment
pour pour l'adaptation au changement
climatique et confort d'été c'était
vraiment la petite on pourra on pourrait
citer également le village olympique
Pleyel qui va se mettre à la géothermie
aussi
etc etc donc et là dessus je vais
laisser Armel rebondir aussi mais sur
les objets de géothermie s'agrandissent
et la boucle d'eau donc c'est vraiment
la mutualisation de besoins c'est-à-dire
que sur une boucle d'eau on va avoir des
bâtiments qui vont avoir besoin de
choses d'autres qui vont avoir besoin de
froid et en mettant tout ça dans un une
boucle d'eau qui va circuler voilà entre
15 et 20 degrés et ben c'est c'est la
meilleure façon en fait de faire du show
et du froid avec une sous-station par en
général par par ensemble de de bâtiments
et et c'est ces objets grandissant il y
a une demande qui va être de plus en
plus critique c'est que cette géo
énergie elle a le bon goût d'être régie
par un décret celui de la GMI la
géothermie de dite de minime importance
que j'appelle vraiment à géothermie dite
de maximum impact en gardant les mêmes
initiales donc cette gmila elle est
régie par ce décret qui fait qu'on peut
faire juste une télé déclaration parce
que le risque est minime et en fait
cette télé déclaration elle est valable
jusqu'à 500 kW de géothermie installée
sortie du sol et ces gros objets font
plus que 500 kW et c'est heureux qu'il
fasse plus de 500 kW le risque est
extrêmement minime et en fait pour ces
gros ces gros réseaux là on va on va
aujourd'hui être obligé de passer par
une instruction au code minier et donc
voilà donc de prendre 18 mois voire plus
pour pouvoir sortir ces projets qui
finalement peuvent ne pas se faire parce
que le délai est trop long et donc il y
a tout un tas de d'études qui montrent
que le risque est minime notamment quand
on est sur certains types de thé de
technologie dites sur sonde pour
permettre la mutualisation de ses
besoins et de passer plutôt sur ces
boucles d'eau
je laisse compliquer sur le côté micro
grid
merci
en fait ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que la prise de terre
on va chercher à l'équilibrer donc on va
pas prendre que du chaud ou que du froid
c'est à dire que sur une année on va
vouloir du chaud du froid pour qu'elle
marche de manière la plus efficiente
possible ensuite quand on va faire un
investissement ce qui va coûter c'est
les sondes
ce qu'on a intérêt à faire
j'ai envie de dire c'est un saturé le
sous-sol pour venir pour avoir la
capacité à venir prendre le plus de
calories et de frigori que le sol peut
nous délivrer mais ça ne correspond pas
forcément aux besoins du bâtiment qui en
surface donc je dirais que
structurellement
on va avoir tendance à démarrer des
micro-grides pour venir proposer de
l'énergie au bâtiment qui sont voisins
voilà l'avantage de ça c'est que on
reste pas bloqué sur une technologie
quand on va vouloir aller enfin étendre
ce micro grille on peut très bien
choisir de prendre de la chaleur fatale
qui pouvait être produite de manière de
manière continue mais qui est souvent
produite de manière intermittente
dans le sens où quand on va vouloir
remplacer
un équipement et ben à ce moment-là il y
aura plus de chaleur qui sera produite
par cette équipe là donc c'est bien
parce que ça permet aussi de venir
à ce que faire le fond cette géo énergie
et de venir compléter ensuite par toutes
ces solutions de récupération de
calories ou de frigori qui elles sont
intermittentes et ce qui
ce qui est un frein actuellement parce
que
les propriétaires de ces calories de ces
frigoris fatales non pas du tout envie
de s'engager sur une production continue
voilà et donc typiquement donc on nous
avons des projets où nous savons que ça
va continuer à se développer et nous
investissons dans
un premier chant de sonde et puis
ensuite on va on a déjà prévu d'investir
dans un deuxième troisième quatrième
chanson à côté et de mettre tout ça en
connexion
si on continue dans l'ordre
sur le sujet de l'individuel versus le
versus le collectif
clairement à la finl on est des apôtres
du collectif parce que pour nous on
mobilise des énergies qui sont quand
même techniques et par conséquent c'est
plus facile de les amortir sur un
ensemble de bâtiments que sur sur un
seul bâtiment maintenant ça dépend
vraiment de la typologie
urbaine et donc ça ça renvoie de la
planification territoriale et là c'est
les élus qui ont la main et ils l'ont
d'autant plus qu'il existe maintenant un
décret qui s'appelle le décret
classement des réseaux et qui vous
permet quand vous êtes maire maître
d'ouvrage d'un réseau de chaleur
vertueux de planifier les zones
voulaient développer le réseau si vous
voulez développer le réseau dans des
quartiers qui sont en train de se en
train de se construire vous les intégrer
à votre cartographie et ça vous permet
d'imposer au bâtiment neuf au bâtiment
qui qui subissent une très forte
rénovation rénovation énergétique de ce
raccorder au réseau s'applique
uniquement au bâtiment neuf et est
fortement rénové donc voilà si ça a du
sens d'un point de vue urbanistique
parce qu'on va vraiment développer un
quartier danse vous avez la possibilité
de de le faire en revanche dans les
zones plus pavillonnaires ou avec moins
de moins de densité là où le réseau de
chaleur a moins de sens économique vous
pouvez dire clairement non là je n'ai
pas je ne porte pas de développement du
réseau de chaleur jusque jusque là voilà
donc c'est un dispositif qui est décrié
par certains parce que ils disent que ça
impose une technologie on s'inscrit
totalement en faux parce que le maire
n'est pas obligé de classer son son
réseau c'est une décision voilà du
Conseil du conseil municipal de le faire
ou pas
après sur les sur les réseaux de froid
bah ça a été ça a été très bien dit moi
je trouve pas idiot que quand on crée un
nouveau réseau bon il y a un petit
problème qu'on crée le réseau c'est
qu'il faut ouvrir les trottoirs c'est
pas toujours très très populaire quitte
à le faire autant faire le show et le et
le chaud et le froid et vraiment vous
dire il y en a pas beaucoup
effectivement il y a 33 réseaux de froid
uniquement en France ils sont développés
essentiellement sur des zones tertiaires
la défense le centre le centre de Lyon
parce qu'on considérait à l'époque et
l'ADEME considérait que la climatisation
en règle générale c'était un gâchis
d'énergie ce qui pouvait se comprendre
dans un monde où on n'était pas plus 4
degrés à partir du moment où on est en
chemin vers les plus 4 degrés qu'est-ce
qui se passe on est en train de le
constater tous les jours il suffit de
prendre les statistiques de vente
d'équipement de du ni climat ce qui se
vend comme des petits pains c'est les
climatiseurs de base et le climatiseur
de base en zone urbaine dense et
beaucoup de consommation électrique
puisque des souvent des équipements
chinois pas performants et puis c'est un
petit défaut c'est que ça met du froid
dans le logement mais sergette du chaud
à l'extérieur donc pour l'îlot de
chaleur ça le fait croître et embellir
donc voilà je pense que il y a il y a du
potentiel pour pour les réseaux de froid
pas forcément des grands réseaux parce
que cela ils sont plutôt faits déjà dans
les zones dans les zones tertiaires mais
un peu par un effet tâche d'huile en
partant de bâtiment qui ont vraiment
besoin de froid typiquement les hôpitaux
et ensuite en allant raccorder un
certain nombre de bâtiments aux
alentours et donc on a les solutions de
la géothermie on a les solutions tu as
mentionné là la sothermie il y a un
réseau de chaleur effroi qui vient
d'être mis en service à Annecy ou c'est
le lac
à Paris c'est l'eau de la scène qui
permet d'alimenter fraîcheur de deux
Paris donc là aussi on a une belle
palette de de source de sources
renouvelables pour la fabrication de ce
froid
peut-être un commentaire juste en
prenant un peu de recul au-delà de 2030
le bâtiment bâtiment neuf c'est c'est
peut-être plus de 50 ans un équipement
chauffage réseau de chaleur c'est
les choix qui sont faits il y a des
effets de loking comme on dit dans notre
jargon enfin en tout cas ce sont des
choix de très long terme et donc la
question du bâtiment c'est pas qu'une
question technique comme beaucoup de
sujets qu'on a traité dans le cadre de
la transition énergétique c'est aussi
une question de sociologie et de besoins
des populations alors on a parlé du
confort divers du confort d'été avec le
réchauffement climatique l'adaptation la
fonction d'adaptation des bâtiments mais
il faut aussi intégrer le vieillissement
de la population je crois que ça a été
dit notamment au regard des pilotages
des équipements
c'est pilotage peuvent avoir des
multifonctions aussi pour des personnes
plus âgées ou à mobilité réduite donc
donc ça c'est des choses au vu des
investissements qu'il faut intégrer dans
notre perspective et puis puisque mon
voisin parle des des Chinois et des
lignes de fabrication ça c'est aussi un
sujet qui ne tient beaucoup à coeur
c'est dans d'ici 2050 on a vraiment un
enjeu de réindustrialiser nos filières
stratégiques alors ça va pour les
panneaux solaires donc on voudrait bien
reconstruire une filière
française et européenne pour justement
avec l'autoconsommation le solaire
toiture qui va entrer dans ces dans ces
équipements de bâtiments demain pouvoir
capter la valeur et les emplois associés
et limiter les importations c'est vrai
aussi pour les pompes à chaleur où on a
une avance technologique
et là aussi on doit puisqu'il y a un
programme de pompe à chaleur au niveau
européen dans le repas il y a eu très
important on doit s'attacher aussi à
créer les conditions alors industrielles
te réindustrialisation sur la chaîne de
valeur de ces équipements pour en
capitaliser la valeur pour notre pour
nos économies et puis pour notre société
effectivement
je parle au dernier encore une fois
peut-être merci de vos propos monsieur
le rapporteur effectivement on est
convaincu que les solutions de de gaz
renouvelables c'est vraiment des
solutions j'irai régionales qui sont
aujourd'hui développées dans les régions
et qui a une équipe qui marche bien qui
a une vraie cohérence à avoir c'est vrai
que tant à 2030 qui a 2050 l'histoire
qu'on raconte elle doit être je dirais
cohérente et bien comprise et c'est vrai
que l'utilisation du gaz renouvelable
des produits par les méthaniseurs le
plus logique c'est qu'elle soit très
locale
je parle des certains qui injecte dans
le réseau il y a aussi des méthaniseurs
qui aujourd'hui produisent de
l'électricité et de la chaleur qui font
du biogaz mais sans injecter dans le
réseau il y a certains métalliseurs qui
ont même construit derrière un petit
réseau de chaleur
parce que c'est parce que c'est local et
il chauffe alors c'est pas forcément une
grosse quantité mais il chauffe quand
même les les quelques maisons autour et
je pense qu'il y a une vraie cohérence
et une vraie histoire je dirais humaine
et sociétales à raconter et que c'est
important dans les dans les décisions
qu'on a que cette histoire elle soit
comprise par nos concitoyens je parlais
tout à l'heure du reste à charge mais
c'est aussi la cohérence d'ensemble de
ce qu'on décide qui qui me semble
important et les gaz renouvelables vont
clairement dans ce dans ce dispositif là
peut-être qu'il faut aussi aller jusqu'à
prendre des décisions sur la rénovation
énergétique qui soit pas les mêmes en
fonction du potentiel de production de
tel ou tel énergie et globalement du
potentiel qu'on a dans tel ou telle
région
vous avez rien à rajouter les uns les
autres je crois qu'on a été oui
n'a parlé emploi et que j'avais oublié
de le faire pour vous donner juste le
chiffre de 60 000 emplois
supplémentaires dans les économies
d'énergie et la chaleur renouvelable et
de récupération à horizon 2030 c'est
notre c'est notre estimation 60 000
c'est un peu plus modeste que
l'électricité et du coup je vais citer
un travail qu'on a fait en commun parce
que Christine a parlé de l'EDEC on a
fait un aidek gaz et réseaux de chaleur
associée donc dans les 60000 il y avait
en gros on a 260 000 emplois dans ces
dans ces territoires et donc tout un éde
qui est effectivement un grand enjeu de
de formation de compétences dans les
dans les dans les territoires c'est ça
qui qui est je dirais qui sort de cette
aidek à peu près entre fin ça dépend les
scénarios mais entre à peu près 100 000
emplois qui pourraient être créé tirer à
la fois gaz et solutions de chaleur
associée
et bien il me reste à vous remercier
pour cette table ronde qui était très
complète et puis je vous souhaite une
bonne soirée puisque il est déjà assez
tard merci en tout cas de votre
participation